[Music]
hey what's up guys mkbhd here and
welcome to a quick video about an
impressive knockoff of the product that
never was air power and also be
attempting to set a record for the
shortest mkbhd video of this year 2019
so far we'll see how I do okay so I
posted a video of this on Twitter not
too long ago a couple days ago and it
got a lot of interest and a lot of
questions so for those who haven't seen
it yet this is called err unleashed and
the honest truth is there's a ton of
other wireless chargers that I'd
recommend first before this one because
they're either more functional or
cheaper but if you're just straight-up
trying to get as close to that air power
dream as possible
so clearly they've taken the approach of
trying to create the closest possible
thing to what Apple was going to make
kind of shamelessly because hey why not
so it has this soft touch felt bottom as
Apple probably would and a white smooth
surface up top you supply your own
charging brick to plug it into the non
removable cable so you plug it in and
you can now charge your iPhone your
Apple watch and your wireless charging
air pods on the same white oval-shaped
pad that looks just like air power
okay so natural question why does this
exist an air power doesn't well it's a
little different from what air power was
going to be you can watch my full video
I'll link it right below the like button
on why air power died and what it was
supposed to be but to make a long story
short air power was supposed to be this
magical mat filled with a ton of
overlapping coils so you could drop any
compatible Apple device anywhere on the
mat and it would just start charging
like it was supposed to be really easy
kind of like magic but also really tough
to make and it ended up presenting a lot
of heat issues so this air Unleashed
is just three coils very simply so a Qi
charging coil on the left-hand side
under that plus a Qi charging coil on
the right-hand side under the other plus
and then it's special proprietary Apple
watch charging coil in the indent in the
middle with some magnets so it sort of
fits in there and lines up every time so
the Apple watch of course does not use
qi wireless charging so it won't charge
on the left or right side only in the
middle and of course since it is qi
wireless charging you can put whatever
compatible device you want doesn't have
to be an iphone it could be anything
that wirelessly charges but as you can
see sort of why this layout it's not
perfectly lined up straight across so
this left side as you can see has a
little bit more space so if you're just
ever charging one phone you can pretty
much just toss it down somewhere on here
and you'll have plenty of room and it
lines up pretty well most of the time
that's great if you ever want to charge
a phone and an Apple watch cool but then
once you add a third device that third
one has to be a little bit smaller
because the coil is pushed over here
near the edge and it doesn't have as
much room around it basically means you
can't quite fit another phone on here
without bumping off the Apple watch
which means it's perfect for air pods
but if you get rid of the Apple watch in
the middle
then you can charge two normal-sized
phones no problem okay so some other
questions from when this was posted on
Twitter rich asks basically how fast
these things will be charging which is a
good question because you're basically
splitting your charger from one thing to
three different things charging at once
so I did my own little test I supplied
my own wall adapter which was the one
plus warped charger but basically any
quick charge 2.0 or 3.0 or later brick
will work if you have one or if you buy
another one it's a couple extra bucks
anyway
I plugged it in for about twenty minutes
with the phone starting at fifty percent
and the watch starting at dead so after
leaving them there for the full twenty
minutes all of them charging at once the
phone had gotten up to 56% and the watch
had gone from zero to 11% so quick maths
that's about five and a half hours of
charging the phone from zero to 100 and
about three hours to charge the watch so
and it'll go a little faster if you only
charge one of them at a time but you
know that's not fast wireless charging
by any means that's totally average and
then another question was just does it
get really hot or people wondering if
mine has caught on fire and I'm I'm
happy to report mine has not caught on
fire yet it does get a tiny bit warm but
the devices that are actually charging
usually get more warm than the pad in
the first place so I'm actually not
worried about here oh that's of course
more of a air power reference and then
we'll the D brand skin work on the air
power knock off so yes D brand did make
a joke air power skin for April Fool's
Day but no there were never any official
dimensions released for air power so
that skin was sort of just mocked up to
be roughly correct based on the size of
the iPhone so I cannot confirm that the
skin that D brand made for air power
would actually fit this perfectly yes I
asked that was a conclusion that we came
up with but at the end of the day it's
not bad for a knockoff although I guess
is it really a knockoff if the product
the original product never existed in
the first place I don't know still feels
like they're copying Apple it's an
expensive wireless charger you know
comes with the cable built-in but there
is no brick in the box you'll have to
get one that's separate and we all know
air power was gonna be even more
expensive but this thing is 99 bucks on
their site so like I said there's plenty
of other charges for cheaper
but for apple vibes this is the one if
you live in that ecosystem if you have
an iPhone and then Apple watch and
wireless charging air pods well then
this is all you could Apple have made
this if they wanted to if they just
realized air power as the concept wasn't
gonna work could they have just made
this three coil version yeah I think
they could have but they were so set on
that magic of air power and they don't
want to come up short from what they've
promised people on stage so they just
cancelled it completely so this is the
next best thing right how do we do
shortest video of the year was that
rollable TV video from CES didn't quite
hit that mark but hey this was still a
fun one hope you enjoyed thank you for
watching catch you guys in the next one
peace